yeah I mean it's it's a clash of fans is
there anything else you guys wanted to
go over that you felt like you didn't
get a chance to
no no I think we agreed yeah well I'm
kind of curious on a macro level how do
you feel about all the statements Tate
has made
about young women about how he would
kind of get people into his business do
you have any feelings about the role do
you think all of that was just like
bravado and fake or yeah so I
it seems like it was bravado and fake
and and that's just me being honest
because when you look at what his
operation was based on the evidence that
we've got now it could be he had that
and then he completely downsized his
business and then never no longer had
that or it was just bravado and it
wasn't there in terms of his ethical
framework like I don't agree with it so
for example from my perspective I've my
ethical framework doesn't agree with any
of this exploitation or this sexual
exploitation like like I said both sure
and so when Tristan says he's got like
six girlfriends at the same time and
they all work for him and when Tate says
he's got you know 75 cam girls you think
they're just lying about all that's all
fake I I um 75 is a lot yeah I don't
believe that's a kiss I don't to have 75
girls you would have to have a massive
operation it's just a it's just
propaganda to basically it's similar to
when he says he's a trillionaire you we
know he's not a trillionaire but it's
just a basically propagate your business
propagate he did own all those cars
right
75 girlfriends times let's say you spent
30 minutes with each of them a week so
that's a lot of
what do you think do you think he had a
75 like logically based on what we're
seeing based on the information we've
got now
um I don't know how many he was managing
but based on the videos I've seen based
on ways that I hear them talk about
women and their their strategies and
everything I think that he had a lot of
women that he brought over that thought
they were going to be something special
and ended up working for him and he
ended up like taking most of their money
I do I do think that I I just don't
think that he took most of their money I
think he just followed normal cam
business practices
um and you can see that with the regards
to the fact that basically he says 50
you see in the card documents actually
the worst one is he's only receiving 25
and then others is much less you say
he's only getting 25 it's 25 to him and
25 to his Business Association do you
believe the statements that he said
because if you believe the ones where he
was saying he didn't pay the women
enough do you also believe because I've
seen videos of him saying that he's made
women Millionaires and he's talked about
how rich he's made a lot of these women
yeah but that's usually in defense of
people saying he's exploiting women
he'll say they're like oh well no I've
made the millionaires but when he's
being explicit about that do you believe
that statement No Okay so that's just
weird to me like why wouldn't you
believe that if you believed the other
one because in one he's just giving a
guide on like this is what I do to take
advantage of aluminum and then the other
one somebody's like well aren't you
explaining it's like no I've made the
millionaires well like obviously that's
just a defense of of himself rather than
like he's never said he's never said
that ever in any of the other videos
where he's just being very Frank and
he's talking about how he manages him
he's never been like oh yeah like and
these women make so much money when I've
got them with me his statements are
always like I own them I have access to
all their media I'm the one that chooses
how they get paid um that you know they
don't even see their original paychecks
I handle all the taxes this is what I do
that those are the symptoms so so a
question linked to what you just said do
you agree with his statement that
basically these women on their own would
not have made in mid they wouldn't have
made as hardly any money and it's only
re the only reason they made significant
amount of money and got rich together is
because they joined him and because he
has an expert in the field and he knew
how to propagate the women in in the
manner that he needs to and therefore
they became Rich together do you agree
with us I agree with all of except for
the last part they probably wouldn't
have made as much money they wouldn't
have well let me be clear they wouldn't
have generated as much revenue because I
don't believe any of them kept that much
money but they wouldn't have generated
as much revenue without being connected
to him but that's because he was a
master scam artist right him and Tristan
detailed on multiple shows how they
would scam men over and over and over
again to get money to try to meet these
girls or meet them and scam them out of
more money and that's what they would do
the problem is the destiny when you say
master scammer is basically what you're
referring to is the exploitation of men
and and the issue no no because what
what you're actually referring to is
that basically a man would get hooked by
a woman and then he'd be sending
considerable amount of money to the
woman with the hopes that maybe he could
have a relationship guess what that's
that's the entire sex industry and I
agree they all exploit man no it's not
even close if you have an only fans girl
and you send her money's on unlock a
video or whatever that's you sending her
money to unlike a video that's extremely
different than a girl saying like oh I'm
gonna meet you I'm on my way to the
Embassy like just send me a thousand
more and so like one of these is very
now you might be of the mind and it
sounds like you are which is fine by the
way that all like sex work is some type
of exploitation which is fine but if
you're gonna say that there's levels of
exploitation right paying a girl money
to unlock a video is way different than
a girl promising she's gonna meet you if
you just send her 1 000 Euro more no but
in terms of the cam business you've got
a scenario so you're talking about
scenario when you're unlocking so that's
only fans and that's um a tick tock
isn't it and with only fans that's
actually what he's been charged for he's
not actually being charged with the cam
business just yeah we're not talking
about business
so in terms of the um
can business
or the cam businesses they have the same
type of process where I'm not all of
them obviously because I'm not
generalizing but generally speaking from
many of the people who we've spoken to
they say like yeah the aim of the game
is that where a man likes a woman and
then he can wants to spend time and then
he spends loads and loads and loads of
money now where's the level or extent of
that money we don't know because only
these guys are spoken about it in such a
crude manner but in terms of the rest of
the business we don't know the level of
where they go to sure I mean I've heard
that before but the woman generally
actually meets the guy I've spoken to
I've been friends with uh some very big
cameras and I've heard them talk about
these details right you'll get these
they call them whales your favorite term
um but you get these whales or Oilers
that will spend a whole bunch of money
but they actually do meet the woman now
I'm not saying there might there
probably are girls out there that are
scammers that lie about every meeting
guys I'm sure that happens no no but he
said I would call them scammers as well
but Tristan and Tristan and Andrew very
specifically spoke about how they
masterfully engineered scams on how to
get these guys hooked how to get them to
come back how to mislead them over and
over and over again they were very
explicit about it not every cam girl
does that yeah so I did see a video
where they actually gave examples of
when they met as well so my point is
this that you know when you look at this
exploitation
and who does it you may know somebody
who does less level of exploitation or
whatever it may be but generally the aim
of the game is to get a man hope so you
can get money sure but when even when
you said examples of where they met as
well I remember that clip that's where
Tristan was speaking very specifically
in the beginning sometimes the girls
would finally meet but what they
realized is they could make even more
money if they never met do you think it
was the take clip do you think that the
women were taking advantage of the men
in that situation
if they're receiving a percentage or
maybe a great X percentage that's a
really hard one that the class this is
the problem like you never want to blame
women it's always the guys
I know you're very ideologically driven
on the male version I really couldn't
care less about it that's not what I'm
interested in the example that I was
gonna give and there's a really
difficult question to ask because you
know the uh like the um you know the
Indian scammers for like calling you and
like blah blah blah there's always a
question of like should they be held
accountable for what they're doing and I
don't know if you're like a cog in the
wheel of an entire scam business
um versus like the head I don't know
what the level of responsibilities are
that's a personally it's a hard one for
me to say like by the girls themselves
participating in the scamming yeah it
seems like it but like how responsible
are they well what percentage of the cut
are they getting would they be doing it
on their own are they being directed to
do that by Andrew and Tristan like these
are all things are going to factor into
the autonomy that that person has to be
a scammer the problem with the argument
is that basically you're saying they're
a but actually in reality when it
comes to scamming that individual person
they're the basically the whole show so
it's the individual woman who's
basically exploiting that specific man
so what you're trying to say is guess
what the uh Andrew te is directing
lesser 10 women and all them 10 women
are exploiting so therefore he has a
greater responsibility because he's
partaking in 10 aspects of it but that
woman is a partaking in that aspect so
from a macro level you're right but from
a micro level they're both
partake in the scam and they're both
equal shareholders if they're getting
paid equally maybe even in the microwave
but on the Mac what about micro level
even on the microwave I don't think
you're correct because didn't Andrew and
Tristan talk over and over again about
how they were the ones running the DMs I
think I think Andrew's joke multiple
times on how well the girls in that room
and then I'm in the other room like he's
doing the DMS he said it multiple times
that was one of the reasons why I said
he was making more money with these
girls than they ever could have is
because they'd engineered down to like a
fine perfect formula what they needed to
type the guys in order to get them
hooked no but that's because that was
that was their business model wasn't it
but in reality when you look at it it
was actually specifically the woman who
was in the screen who was basically
um getting the man to be interested in
him so that he could be exploited and
when you look at it as we said if it was
a 50 50 from a micro level they're both
50 responsible if it's a scenario it's
50 25 then what let's say there is a
scenario where she's receiving a greater
Court 70 30 then
like here's the reality right if you've
got a guy that's at the head of a scam
and then he's recruiting people and
paying them to be little scammers and I
guess yeah you could say they share some
responsibility depending on how they
were recruited that's a really important
part uh but they share something
responsibility but most of the
responsibility is always going to go to
the head of that thing of course just
like you're gonna you're gonna blame
like a major dealer over like random
kids dealing on the street of course how
does it depend on how they're recruited
well because if somebody says like Hey
we're gonna go and scam a whole bunch of
men you want to sign up and you sign up
while at that point you're kind of like
you're part of the scam you're long for
the right that's kind of your fault but
if somebody says like hey like I really
love you I want you to come to Romania I
want you to be with me we're going to
work together we're going to be a team
of blah blah blah and then you get
things like listen I need you to work
for 12 hours a day we're gonna handle
your damn spray it's it's a lot
different the level of responsibility so
the issue I love you but we're gonna
scam a bunch of them did I ever say that
no no but that's basically what you said
no that's not what I said
you said basically if they're dating and
then he she does it it's a different
level of responsibility I just don't
understand why if you're dating yeah of
course like once you're married the
relationship changes significantly right
if I found a random girl on the street
and I started to get her to scampi I was
like hey we should scan people the level
of like autonomy that she has as a
person is going to change versus like my
wife because I probably have a lot more
leverage where my wife because we're
married right or my wife over me right
it's gonna have a lot more leverage
because we're married so yeah that's
going to change the relationship it's
going to change quite a bit there the
radius should be different but the
actual impact would not be different
we're not talking about it yeah not
because we're talking about the impact
of the exploitation and then in terms of
uh the women
um when you look at the women that he's
been who are basically in this case all
of them have been all of them up to now
what we know about fall being in the sex
industry but also again it's not a level
of exploitation where you're getting
some victim or from a poor country who
basically didn't know about any of this
and then you're making them into it but
nearly all of them are you know in the
have been in the sex industry or have
been in a more severe version of this of
the webcam industry before they ever met
him um so Tate's original claim was that
most of the women now I don't know for
the victims that have come forward they
might not have been on the Sexes yeah
but Tate's original claim was that most
of the women that have worked for him
weren't involved in the sex industry
report now and you agree that doesn't
matter in the sense yeah but um also
when you say the impact equals the
exploitation that's not true the
exploitation is going to line the intent
right if I go to a shop to get my car
fixed and they try to repair my brakes
and they legitimately make a mistake
right well I'm gonna go back and I'll
get you know my breaks fixed again
because they messed up but that's a lot
different than somebody intentionally
saying like ah we're gonna fake this one
and charge them anyway right even if the
impact is the same the intent is going
to
this exploitation is a crime that exists
in the mind it's not just in the final
outcome I agree intense is important and
the intent is the same so because if you
get your wife to basically exploit
someone or you get a random person to
explain someone the intent is the same
what your argument is is that the
influence is different but the intent is
the same well do you think any of these
girls that worked with Tate would have
been this scammy with men how they not
worked with hate I thought we all agreed
earlier I believe a lot of girls are
better this scammy with men for free
okay I don't know what question you're
answering would they have been like yeah
so so in terms of these women yes they
would have been scammy if they had it so
but the only difference is if he's right
which I think we both agree that if
these women are on their own their
operation wouldn't be on the same level
so because the operation would be on the
same level maybe not so but if the
operation was on the same level of
course they would do we have any
evidence that any of these women had
like other men running their DMS and
that they were running long-term scams
on any of their male clients which which
are the women any of them now what do
you mean sorry I don't know because the
claim that I'm making for the
camping business is that the girls were
told by the Tates to intentionally
mislead men about possibly meeting them
one day and that was a way that they
they collected more and more funds yeah
are any of these women
um that have come forward as victims
before the Andrew Tate thing were they
doing those types of behaviors so
basically they were all in the same
business or were so some of them are
strippers some of the webcam webcam
business and so on and so forth so but
in terms of whether they were doing that
there's no evidence that they did it
before or with the tits because none of
that information again so even in the
take case there's nothing about that
okay well if Tates if the tits are lying
then then obviously I don't agree the
expectation is there but I mean if
they're being truthful I mean that's a
level of exploitation that I don't
believe any of those women would have
engaged in had they not been part of the
tickets what do you mean by language
Define yeah I I if with the tapes were
saying were true the way they were in
their business then I would say that
that level of exploitation is not
something that they would have taken
part in before just stripping is not the
same as lying to men saying you're going
to meet the mixer Etc but it's possible
the tapes were just lying about
everything in which case then right yeah
yeah and I disagree I'll say they would
have if they were at the same level of
Fame I'm curious would your opinion
change if they had only fans accounts
today
so like if the girls in 2023 had only
fans accounts no because I don't
consider only fans exploitation
I don't get you it's not the same thing
as can work it's very similar wait what
did I say was the exploitative part of
the campaign
um you said that the men coming out to
try to see them yes okay but you don't
okay VA so you're if I'm only here is
that you don't think that's exploitative
at all wait that was not expected you
don't think only fans are exploitative I
never said it's not exploitative but if
we're gonna measure something it's going
to be completely different if somebody's
so many only fans are saying like donate
one thousand dollars and we can meet
someday and she's lying she's never
gonna be the guy and she keeps
soliciting donors then I would say
that's the same thing that's what they
were doing yeah I'm shining Point
Destiny but the thing is in terms of
this I know we're going back to the
charges but they're not actually being
charged for webcam they're being charged
for only funds and uh Tick Tock so on
that basis your argument about human
trafficking doesn't it but they might be
doing the same thing on only fans right
that might have been the only fencing
but I've been telling them like send me
this money and then you'll you can meet
us at this area or whatever like they
could have been running that's game on
only fans as well I don't know if they
were or not because I don't know yeah we
haven't got no data evidence for that so
I've only heard him talk about his prior
camping business I don't think they've
talked about the current only fan stuff
unless it applies to the current
business as well so in terms of that we
don't have any information about them
doing that whatsoever no one has claimed
it to be the case
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible